okay it's time for a little bit of uh
anthropology some historical research
today we're going to go back and rewatch
as much as we can stomach of my very
first episode we're going to move the
clock back 5 years to uh April 2nd of
2018 was the first episode with me
homeless in my car and I have to tell
you that I don't like to watch my old
stuff because you have to understand
it's like a lose lose proposition
because either it's really good and then
you worry that you were better back then
than you are now and you've fallen off
or it's terrible and embarrassing and
then you're just embarrassed how
embarrassing so no matter what it's
emotionally painful to watch anything
that you've done prior to the day before
yesterday uh but I'm going to endure
that pain today so let's get into
episode one of the Matt wall show called
uh never apologize to the Pitchfork mom
is the name of the episode a theme that
of course I've returned to frequently in
preceding years and uh let's put it on
all right so Laura and Ingram is taking
a vacation um okay pause it I can't I
can't actually do
this so first of all we don't have to
worry about that it's it's too good and
makes me feel bad about what I'm doing
now so that's not a concern that concern
is off the table it's not it's we don't
have to worry we don't have to worry the
show is better back then that's the good
part that's the good news um the what we
do have to worry about though is is
everything else that's happening um and
we have to start with my appearance
which which I don't know what's going on
with the haircut it's like a little bit
of Donald Trump it's a little bit of an
unkempt sixth grader on school picture
day um there's the the Cyclops
glasses not the best look and then
there's the faux leather jacket was
definitely faux leather it wasn't real
that's not real leather that was a $30
jacket probably so it was the faux
leather jacket with the salmon striped
wrinkled shirt that's not even buttoned
all the way and then it goes the worst
the most egregious offense of all of
course is the is the beard which is way
to Trimm down and that's like if you're
going have a beard like that there's no
reason to have a beard so you really got
to commit one way or another you have
the beard you don't have the
beard so here's what I'm wondering when
I watch this which is so I don't put the
blame on myself as you might expect I
put the blame on everybody else like why
did no one else say to me hey you look
like on camera let's figure
something out no one said that to me it
might shock you to learn it no one ever
said that not one time nobody so I feel
betrayed this is not my fault all right
let's continue vacation amid the
advertiser boycott and all the outrage
that's still growing it hasn't died down
you know here we are four or five days
later because of this you know
unnecessary and dumb tweet that she sent
about David hog unnecessary and dumb
okay get let just stop just get to the
point like what they said this just
babbling in the beginning no one knows
what I'm talking about uh I'm not hooked
in at all to that I I don't even know
what I'm I don't know what I'm talking I
know that La it's something to do with
Laura Ingram I don't know I I I'm not
interested I'm already bored and I'm the
one who said this couldn't get into it
explain yourself what didn't you like
about it insists upon itself but I'm not
I'm also not paying attention to what
I'm saying because I'm still hung up on
some of the Aesthetics of this broadcast
like there's a random book bag in the
background why is that there I actually
remember the so I remember that oddly
enough I remember before I hit record on
the on the camera I remember I look back
and said there's a book bag there I
should probably move it and then I said
H it's not worth it so it wasn't worth
the effort for me to turn around and
move the book bag over and so I said
we'll just keep it on camera cuz why
does it
matter speaking of the Aesthetics you
notice that you'll notice the fence in
the background there and uh so a lot of
times people will ask me back in the car
cast days which by the way is what I'm
calling it now where did I go to do the
podcast and really nobody asked me that
because nobody was watching and no one
cares but uh if you were wondering that
um this very first episode I did outside
of my house that's my yard there and I
stopped uh doing that at because what
would happen is I'd be in the car doing
the podcast and my kids would come out
and they would just stand in the yard
and stare at me and then maybe feel
self-conscious and then my wife would
come out and my my my kids would say
what's daddy doing in the car and she
would say oh Daddy's pretending to have
a job kids she didn't say that exactly
but she could have said that and and it
would not have been
inaccurate so anyway So eventually I
found a new spot at a like at a parking
lot like a shopping Center parking lot
and I would do it there I'm in a parking
garage right next to an overflowing
trash can and then instead of my kids
staring at me it would be random people
walking by staring at me which was
better I guess um and I remember and
this is true one time in one of these
parking lots doing the show doing the
show it's not a show and a guy actually
came up and knocked on the window and
said hey you okay in there am I okay
what do you like what do you why of
course I'm okay why do but then I
realized I look like I'm having a
psychotic
episode so I guess he was checking to
make sure that I wasn't you know
Vladimir Putin called the US Dollars
drop in dominance objective and
irreversible as Brazil Russia India
China and South Africa formally agreed
to use local currencies in trade instead
of the US dollar as demand for the
dollar weakend the buying power of the
dollar weakend this is why Birch gold is
busier than ever investors and Savers
are looking to harness the power of
physical gold held in a tax sheltered
IRA and you can too you can protect your
IRA or 401K by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold as that US dollar
continues to receive pressure from
foreign countries digital currency and
central banks arm yourself with
information on how to protect your
savings learn if gold is right for you
too text Walsh to
898988 plus braiding with the Better
Business Bureau thousands of happy
customers and countless festar reviews I
trust Birch gold to help you diversify
into gold if a central bank digital
currency becomes a reality it'll be nice
to have some gold to depend on again
text Walsh to 98
9898 all right in fact let's just you
know just to frame this and in case
you're um in case you forget let's just
um let just remind you what the Tweet
was what this offending tweet was and
this is the tweet that has potentially
destroyed her career so I'm holding the
phone in my hand you know over a dozen
while delivering and all these and this
is the Tweet okay um got pull up the
Tweet because I didn't have it ready 28
you you stop it again um so I'm still
not paying attention to the content at
all I'm not interested in the content
the other question I get is uh this is a
real question that that comes up a lot
it's a fair question which is like why
well how is this ever a thing why did
anyone ever think that this was a good
idea for you to do a show in the car and
the the answer to that is that when I
first started the daily wire um before I
even had a podcast they wanted me to uh
to record like little video rant just
because they need they needed content
and so you know we and I was writing and
I worked D and I was mostly writing and
they said you need to make more content
than that we've got a squeeze every bit
of content we can out of here and so
they wanted me to start doing this
little every once in a while just like
do a little video and uh and post it it
wasn't a lot of Direction and I did
those in my car because only because it
was the only place I could go where it
was quiet and I thought that no one's
going to watch it anyway so they so it
doesn't really matter what it looks like
and then when DW came to me and and uh
said that they would like me to do a
Daily Show and I was meeting in Jeremy's
office in Los Angeles at the time and
they said want me to do a Daily Show
and uh and I said this sounds great so
what like Studio wise what are we going
to do about the studio and he said well
keep doing it in your car because we
love the look we love the look in the
car and and he even said this is true he
even said that maybe down the line I
could move into a studio but maybe we
would make the studio look like the
inside of a car so that I wouldn't be in
a car anymore but it would look like it
so we' still have that great look and I
think I sort of bought that at the time
but now now I'm looking at this and I'm
like there's no way you like that look
that's not it's not no there's no way
there's no way you looked at this and
said that's a great look you know what
that's the look that's the look that's
going to take you to the top kid that
look right
there so I think it was more like hey
you don't even know how to comb your
hair so we're not going to put a lot of
money into this operation you got to you
got to prove it you got to earn it so I
think it was more that which is
fair all right well watch how don't know
how how far into this video have made I
think we've made it about 15 seconds 50
seconds all right let's see if we can
make it to a minute let's put 10 seconds
on the clock go ahead um she the Tweet
is linking to an article it says David
hog rejected by four colleges to which
he
appli how do I still have a job how how
did that happen I will get myself so I'm
you know I'm looking at this I'm like
What's the bright side where can I give
myself some credit for where are the
strong points and I give myself credit
for one thing I don't think it doesn't
look or sound like I'm reading you sure
about that but uh and I don't know if
this is good or bad but I definitely was
reading so I would write out a monologue
and then I would go and print it at
Staples because we didn't have a printer
at our house and then I would go into my
car when I would usually just stay
parked in the Staples parking lot and
the
employees at Staples were definitely
wondering because they're like who is
this disheveled weirdo coming in here
every day and printing out a little
speech and then delivering it to nobody
in his car outside imagine how confused
everybody was and that was my audience
too by the way so the employees at
Staples were kind of like looking out
the window he's in is he in his car what
is he doing in there that was the whole
audience of the show that was it that
was the entire audience um but at least
I had an audience but now everything has
changed uh now I'm in this beautiful
Studio looking out over trees and
mountains very real trees and mountains
are you sure about that and I think
we've walked down memory lane enough I
one I remove these early episodes from
the internet now and burn them that's
what I would if that was even possible
that's what I would prefer to
do thanks for
[Music]
watching why